*applaudissements*
Vous avez passé un bon Nouvel An ?
Écoutez je fais cette petite vidéo juste parce que,
je viens de vivre les 4 mois de ma carrière les plus DINGUES.
Et j'ai besoin de vous en parler pour que vous compreniez un petit peu
ce qu'il s'est passé, de l'autre côté de la caméra, ce que j'ai vécu moi, Lucas, en tant qu'humain.
Voilà j'ai besoin de vider mon sac finalement, mais positivement, pas négativement
C'est bien de le vider positivement, je trouve, son sac et on a besoin de le faire.
En Juillet et Août dernier j'avais fait une petite pause de 3 semaines sur YouTube.
Et c'est très stressant, rien n'est plus stressant pour un Youtuber que de faire une pause
et de ne pas mettre de contenu en ligne.
On a l'impression que les autres Youtubers vont t'absorber,
vont devenir les mecs à la mode et que toi tu vas tomber
aux oubliettes instantanément.
C'est complètement con comme réflexion en plus parce que c'est faux.
J'étais serein en plus parce que je revenais avec une grosse vidéo,
avec la vidéo des 10 millions.
C'était une expérience qui m'a vraiment remué, qui m'a vraiment chamboulé,
de rencontrer les gens, que ce ne soit plus que des pseudos
bon je dis tout ça dans la vidéo *blablabla* vous connaissez.
Mais c'est vraiment quelque chose qui m'a profondément marqué.
Et qui m'a donné une envie énorme de me dépasser,
à la rentrée, de faire des trucs toujours plus gros.
D'ailleurs à la fin du vlog pour ceux qui ont regardés
je m'étais trompé, j'avais dis "Néo" au lieu de dire "Noé".
William
Charlène
Néo
*erreur de prononciation*
J'suis un connard, voilà, Noé excuse moi.
*rire*
Je m'excuse...
Je m'excuse 4 mois après mais c'est mieux que de pas s'excuser ok ?
Gros changement majeur cette année, je me suis mis au live sérieusement sur ma chaîne "Twitch"
Vous êtes plus de 800 000 à avoir follow la chaîne
tous les jeudi vous êtes entre 30 000 et 70 000
et surtout vous êtes plus d'1 600 000 à vous êtes abonnées à la chaîne "SQUEEZIE LIVE"
alors je donne des chiffres mais c'est un peu nul de parler en chiffres
mais c'est pour vous montrer à quel point c'est un truc qui a...qui a marché, qui vous a plu
pour moi commencer les lives c'était un peu une libération
parce que c'est un domaine que je connais beaucoup moins que YouTube
j'fais un peu un petit pas dans l'inconnu, je sort de ma zone de confort
et du coup ça m'a vraiment fait du bien de découvrir des choses
de me planter, d'être briffé par des potes, d'avoir des conseils
j'avais vraiment l'impression d'être en 2010 sur YouTube quoi
et surtout ça permet de jouer avec des potes aux jeux vidéos, le temps d'une soirée
comme j'l'ai fait pendant très longtemps dans ma vie
mais comme je ne l'ai pas fait depuis quelques années ça me manque beaucoup
donc voilà, tous les jeudi 20h/minuit, c'est une soirée qui me...qui en fait me fait beaucoup de bien en tant qu'humain
j'oublie un peu les caméras, j'oublie un peu tout ça
et juste je me tape des barres avec mes potes, et c'est génial
donc merci "GOTAGA", meci "Doigby" et merci "Micka" d'êtes là tous les jeudis, avec moi
parce que je pense vous ne vous rendez pas compte à quel point ça me fait du bien, à quel point ça me fait plaisir
c'est la fin du point live n'hésitez pas à vous abonnez à la chaîne best of pour ne rater aucun best of
et vous abonnez à la chaîne "Twitch" pour ne rater aucun jeudi soir
*rire*
après ça il y a eu le clip 90 versus 2000 avec McFly et Carlito
j'étais trop content de bosser sur une musique avec eux parce qu'ils sont vraiment très très forts
Ils font...ils ont fait vraiment des musiques que je trouve géniales
on a l'habitude avec McFly et Carlito de faire des vidéos
en impro comme quand on ouvre des objets
quand on fait, sur leur chaine, divers concept qui nous font trop marrer, trop cool
mais... il manquait ce truc là où on se challenge, où on se lance dans un gros projet
où on écrit, où on réfléchit, où on veut vraiment se faire kiffer
90 versus 2000 c'est le résultat de ça
de 3 cerveaux qui ont donné le maximum d'eux mêmes
et voilà c'est le premier gros projet qu'on fait
avec euh... David et Raph qui sortent des vidéos
impros, facecam, et j'en suis très content
et j'espère que il y'en aura d'autres donc voilà un gros bisou à David et Raph
euh j'vous adore les gars.
Après ça je... j'suis pas... j'suis allé en Islande
aussi en fin d'année c'était sympa il faut le noter
ça aussi c'étais très très cool même si la météo était complètement contre nous.
Il y'a du brouillard, il pleut, la caméra on ne peut pas la sortir plus de 3 minutes
sinon il y a de la buée ou des gouttes sur l'objectif
C’est toujours drôle de partir avec une équipe de tournage
Et de vivre les choses ensemble, les intempéries, les couac,
Tout ces trucs là c’est trop marrant à vivre
En fait c’est des expériences humaines formidables les tournages
Et en fait, même pas devant la caméra
Il se passe énormément de choses qui nous font grandir
Et qui font qu’on apprécie ce métier donc voilà
J’ai énormément de chances de vous avoir comme communauté parce que
je peux faire ce que je veux comme vidéo
tout ce que je veux
que ce soit des musiques, que ce soit pas des musiques
que ce soit des courts métrages, que ce soit des vidéos réactions
que ce soit des vidéos où je parle d’un truc que j'aime
et vous êtes là, vous êtes au rendez-vous
et vous avez l’air d’aimer en plus
et vous me montrez en plus que vous aimez
je trouve ça extraordinaire ça me permet d’être libre
d’experimenter pleins de choses
de kiffer 20 fois plus que si j’étais bloqué dans une catégorie de vidéo
donc merci à vous pour ça bien évidemment
Après ça j’ai fais mon premier court métrage
sur lequel on a taffé pendant 9 mois
j’ai vu des gens pas comprendre pourquoi ça méritait 9 mois de travail
mais en fait la préparation
l’élaboration des costumes, les retours avec la marque,
parce que c’était sponsorisé par Ubisoft,
la construction du décor, l’élaboration du scénario
faire en sorte que le scénario soit réalisable
que tout rentre dans les frais, fin bref
mine de rien, c’est plusieurs mois de travail en fait
mais bon je comprend que des gens s’en rendent pas compte etc...
même moi, y’a pas si longtemps... je ne me rendais pas du tout compte de ça
du temps qu’il fallait passer pour avoir un truc de 4 minutes quoi *rire*
mais voilà je suis content j’ai mis un pied dans le court métrage
J'ai mis un pied dans autre chose que juste des musiques ou des vidéos impro
Et ça me fait très plaisir et j'espère que cette année je vais faire d'autre chose du genre
Et la sortie du court métrage sur Rainbow
pour moi représentait beaucoup beaucoup
Après ça, la dernière vidéo de "l'épopée Alain Rey"
On va l'appeler "l'épopée Alain Rey"
Avec Flo et Oli que je connais depuis plusieurs années maintenant
Et c'est vraiment émouvant comme truc parce que
Le délire autour d'Alain Rey il s'est créé spontanément
Juste à cause d'un bandeau qu'il y avait sur le dictionnaire
Et on en a fait derrière un clip et on a fait derrière un dernier clip là qui est sorti
On a prit le concept, on la usé dans tous les sens
Mais j'trouve qu'on finit en beauté avec un truc qui est bossé, bien
Et on a pas finit avec un truc en mode comme un film
Vous savez quand il font une suite et que c'est de la merde
Et tu te dis "Oh ils auraient pas dû continuer"
Bah je trouves que là on a bien fait de continuer et de finir de cette manière là
Par contre il faut savoir dire "stop", il faut savoir s’arrêter
Même si c'est un concept très fort qui marche beaucoup
Voilà, jpense que c'est une page qui se tourne aussi sur ça
Et j'étais trop ému parce que avec Flo et Oli on se connaît depuis des années
Ils ont avancés dans leur carrière
J'ai avancé dans la mienne
Et on a le même âge
Donc y a pleins de truc qu'on peut se dire, qu'on a en commun
Fin c'est super intéressant
Donc voilà je suis très heureux de ça
Et puis encore une fois vous avez étés d'un soutien Inébranlable !!
Sur cette série de vidéos
C'est la série que jcrois qui vous a le plus plu
Donc voilà je suis heureux que ce dernier opus vous ai plu
Et puis qui sait, peut-être qu'on inventera un autre concept avec eux
Dans.. cette année
Ou l'année d'après je sais pas
Ou l'année encore d'après
ET enfin il y'a eu le clip des Frenetic
Plus de 30 ans après la sortie de leur single
Ca y est, ça marche enfin
J'ai pu mettre le clip de leur  single "I feel a man" sur ma chaîne Youtube
Et vous avez vraiment bien aimé la musique pour la plupart
Et surtout des jeunes, y'a plein de jeunes qui ont aimé la musique
Et je suis très content parce que c'est quand même une musique des années 80
Et c'était pas gagné
Mais moi, c'est une époque que j'adore, c'est des musiques que je trouve géniales
Donc je suis très content que ça vous aie plu
Et en voyant le clip je suis sûr qu'ils s'étaient éclatés sur le tournage
Ils ont l'air d'avoir passé un très bon moment
Ils ont même chacun créé un profil Instagram
Et ils sont à fond, ils ont  répondu à des fans
Ils ont.. 'fin bref ils vient le délire à fond donc je suis très content pour eux
Et qui sait, peut être qu'ils feront d'autres musiques
Vu le soutien que vous leur avez apporté, donc voilà, on verra ça
En tout cas, c'était un très très beau projet pour finir l'année, c'était très mignon comme histoire
Et voilà, et voilà, on est à cette nouvelle année, les fêtes sont passées, le nouvel an vient de passer
Au moment où je fais cette vidéo c'est pas encore passé pour être franc avec vous
Mais je me prends euh... Je fais un tout petit peu, juste un tout petit peu d'avance de vidéo
Mais sans me forcer, je kiffe faire ça
Et juste je suis choqué  de ces 4 mois, c'était INTENSE en terme de taf, je vous avoue
Mais c'était aussi riche en terme d'expérience, de relations humaines, etc, c'était incroyable
Et chaque année je me dis "Comment je vais réussir à faire des trucs qui me plaisent,
A continuer kiffer ce que je fais, à me stimuler, à mettre des petits pas dans l'inconnu et tout,
A sortir de ma zone de confort ?"
Et là je trouve que j'ai réussi plus que jamais ça et j'suis vraiment content
Et, et puis voilà, vos retours sont là, vos gentils mots sont là
Je vois de plus de plus en plus de gens qui ont mon âge, ou qui sont un peu plus vieux
Qui m'arrêtent dans la rue, qui regardent les vidéos, qui me font leur retours
Et rien ne me fait plus plaisir que ça, de me dire que putain,
Je touche les gens de mon âge et un peu plus vieux
Et je touche aussi la génération juste en dessous !
Je veux continuer d'être sincère, euh... Avec moi-même je veux dire,
A ne pas m'enfermer dans un format, m'enfermer dans un concept, etc
Mais à toujours faire ce que j'aime, quitte à ce que ça surprenne négativement les gens
C'est pas grave, il faut tenter des choses
Il peut y avoir des erreurs, il peut y avoir des trucs qui bident,
Mais voilà, je veux continuer à faire ce qui me fait kiffer sur Youtube
Et à transmettre le plus de bonnes choses possibles
J'ai appris énormément de choses ces dernières années
Et j'ai fait plein de trucs de merde, plein d'erreurs
Je vois tous les retours, je vois tout ce que vous dites, vous en faîtes pas
Et j'essaie de prendre du recul par rapport à ce que vous dites
Mais quand même il faut que j'intègre tout ça
Pour pouvoir apprendre de mes erreurs et avancer et me...
Et évoluer en fait, tout simplement.
Après cette vidéo là y'aura un best-of des best-of de la chaîne SqueezieLive
*bruit bizarre* Et oui il est allé chercher loin Lucas
*rire* Pour avoir une vidéo
Tous les best-of font déjà plus de 10 minutes et y'en a déjà plus de 30, des best-of
Et en fait j'aimerais faire un "Master best-of"
Qui regroupe le... les 20 secondes parfaites de chaque best-of
Le meilleur moment de chaque best-of
Donc voilà, ça sortira dans les prochains jours
Et puis voilà j'espère que les lives continueront à vous plaire,
Que les vidéos continueront à vous plaire,
Que, que moi je continuerais à faire ce qui me plaît
Et que je continuerait à être sincère avec moi et avec vous
C'est le plus important pour moi aujourd'hui,
Et puis merci pour toutes ces années,
Merci pour cette année qui est folle
Je sais que je fais un debrief tous les 3 ou 4 mois en vidéo
Mais, voilà, j'en ai besoin, à chaque fois ça me fait du bien
Et à chaque fois je me dis que j'ai bien fait de le faire
Et que, que je le referais
Merci beaucoup du coup pour la fin de l'année dernière
C'était génial et puis, voilà, on se retrouve très bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo,
Nouvau projet, nouveau live
Nouveaux trucs cette année, qui j'espère vous plairont
J'ai l'impression que tout ça est nul à regarder et ne sert à rien
Mais ça m'a fait du bien,
Je suis partagé entre deux sentiments opposés, c'est terrible !
Je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo !
Ciao les gens ! A bientôt pour le best-of et à bientôt pour des vraies vidéos
Voilà, euh, où je parle de différentes choses comme d'habitude
Et puis, euh... Yes, je suis gêné !
C'est bizarre, je suis gêné dans cette fin de vidéo,
Comme si j'avais honte de ce que je viens de faire,
Mais il faut pas !
*Outro*